a day considered inconceivable by many
a final goodbye to veteran al jazeera
journalist shireen abu akley
[Applause]
from thousands of people lining the
streets of occupied east jerusalem
here is where she was born 51 years ago
and now laid to rest
people's reactions a testament to how
loved shireen was across the arab world
[Applause]
chilean was loved by so many people and
her
her killing
is a blow to the world internationally
it's a blow to us nationally and it's a
blow to me personally she went into the
hearts of every single palestinian and i
dare say every arab
household because of her touching
reporting and the way that she had of
bringing to life the reality of israel's
brutal occupation
the funeral procession began on friday
in saint louis french hospital in the
shechera neighborhood
but as it got underway this happened
[Applause]
palestinians holding her coffin were
charged and beaten by israeli forces
mourners struggled to prevent it hitting
the ground
[Applause]
the funeral procession later resumed and
reached a cathedral in the christian
quarter of the old city where a service
was held
brought the message of every palestinian
uh suffering every palestinian uh
difficult conditions to the whole world
god created life not to be assassinated
but to be nurtured
many of abu akla's friends and
colleagues from the occupied west bank
were forbidden from attending her
funeral by israeli authorities
a colleague called her funeral the
longest in recent palestinian history
40 kilometers of love from janine to
jerusalem
albert was shot dead in the occupied
west bank city of janine on wednesday
her body later carried through the
streets as a sign of mourning and
respect
[Music]
[Applause]
was buried next to her parents grave at
the mount zion protestant cemetery
many are calling her the daughter of
palestine and says her work life and
message will never be forgotten
laura bowden manly al jazeera